Reese Davis back here on the show how
are you Reese I'm doing great rich and I
felt terrible about that I really wanted
to see your kids and I'm sorry we missed
each other in Pasadena III it was in uh
let's put it this way trying to get to
you they they saw I think a quarter of
the crowd trying to go in the other
direction it was insane
I mean before we get to tonight I mean
what a great setting that was in the
Rose Bowl Reese no it was not great what
it's beautiful rich I think it's the
best setting for college football and I
understand why they won't but there's a
big part of me that wishes they would
just play the national championship game
in Pasadena every year because the
setting is perfect for a huge game and
Georgia and Oklahoma certainly lived up
to it last week and Georgia I mean that
kid from what do you expect from him
tonight I mean cuz he eat he plays he
plays like as level-headed his brady for
somebody who's 19 years old plet was
playing high school football last year
he was in remarkable last week
completely unflappable and I think
that's what really makes him good the
people that you talk to whether it's his
teammates or his coaches talk about how
as soon as he stepped on campus in the
spring that he assumed command and
didn't act as if he were just going to
back up Jacob Eason and when the
opportunity arose he stepped in and just
put a stranglehold on the job he is he
really throws with anticipation he plays
with fearlessness they haven't asked him
to do a lot they run 68% of the time
nobody doesn't run the triple option
runs more often in Georgia and but still
I think he's shown that he is completely
capable of making big plays in the
passing game if that's what they need
tonight you know they have a big big
big-time five star quarterback coming in
next year named Justin fields who
everybody raves about and after watching
swamp play in the Rose Bowl
my question was exactly when does this
guy think he's gonna play because you
know I don't know I don't know how in
the world you'd blow 11 out of that seat
in anytime soon because I was as
impressed as you were Reese Davis
joining me here on the Rich Eisen show
prior to hosting tonight's coverage on
ESPN of the national championship game
between Georgia and Alabama we had
Fowler on Friday our buddy Bruce Feldman
on a week before and I told Fowler what
Feldman said and I'm gonna say it to you
here as well that that it's tough tough
to envision Alabama losing the street
fight that Oklahoma would have given him
a totally different game in it certainly
in a manner that would normally you know
historically conventionally wisdom wise
confound Alabama what do you think about
this evening I think you're exactly
right I do think that Georgia is as
well-equipped to beat them as any team a
face that plays that style but the next
team to beat them playing that style
beat them at their own game
maybe the first I guess you could at
least since they've started this dynasty
in 2008 perhaps you could argue Ohio
State it's not you know pure Pro style
stuff but more like what you'll see from
Georgia certainly with some wrinkles but
you know hyoe state certainly ran it at
them and control the line of scrimmage
and beat them in that you know barber
all street fight type of game
historically that is favored Alabama
whether it will tonight I think it
depends largely on the quartet play and
also how well Alabama adjust to losing
Anthony Jennings he's he's one of their
linebackers yet another linebacker
injury for the Crimson Tide and he was
the best player on the field
against Clemson and my judgment he was
hurt late in that game won't be able to
play so it's yet another test of
Alabama's death so give me something to
look for tonight I'm sure you've been
exposed to so many storylines throughout
the season of these two teams separately
and now that they're on the same field
tonight
what should viewers of this game be
looking forward to getting inkling as to
what the final result might be research
how efficient Jalen Hertz is in the
passing game I do not believe that
Alabama will be able to beat Georgia
with him throwing for just over 100
yards a game now that said will they use
him a lot and in the quarterback run
game there has been rumblings for the
last month that Alabama would not
hesitate to go to their backup
quarterback to a tongue of Aloha who is
but a highly touted guy and can really
throw the football so I think how
efficient is Jalen on first down how is
efficient is the in the past
game and whether they use strictly Hertz
or whether they get into a situation
where they feel like they have to bring
in the freshmen to try to make something
happen through the air and when you talk
to your colleagues and people around
town there in Atlanta who do you who are
you hearing most is winning to note what
do you think you know rich it's really
it's a lot like what you just said I
think everybody's afraid to pick against
Alabama because a lot of us did in the
Sugar Bowl and they proved me wrong so
often but the five feels like Georgia to
me and now maybe that's the excitement
of 37 years since the national
championship home state or whatever it's
almost as if there's an anticipation
that George is gonna win but everybody's
afraid to say it because of Alabama's
great success in these situations over
the years so you know I don't know how
many people know this but I just you
know when I started doing sports center
with you I did notice that Alabama ring
that you used to have on I know if you
still work no I do not okay yeah but
stuff to do what you do for a living in
helped add on now yeah but I've back in
the day when we were doing sports
sitting together when I first started
out you did so be in class of 88 you
would know the answer this question has
Nick Saban already earned the mantle of
greatest coach in the history of that
school your thoughts
rece davis without question and in my
judgment he's also the greatest coach in
the history of college football
regardless of what happens tonight
now if you're just into counting
championships and that's how you define
it then i guess he has to win another
one or maybe when two more in pass fair
bryan and i don't you know i when you
say things like that it all often seems
as if you're sliding someone else and I
don't mean it that way but this dynasty
this consistency has been unprecedented
if they win tonight is five and nine
years nobody's come close to that but
while that is the first line on the
resume for Nick Saban winning all of
these championships to me the second
line is that he fixed LSU rich girl
growing up in the south for my entire
life
LSU was a coaching graveyard and he went
in and fixed it and it has been
sustainable through a couple of other
coaches maybe not at the level he had it
but certainly still largely fixed the
former LSU coach head coach after after
he lost his
LSU his next job as a head coach was at
my high school
LSU chewed up spit out an eight coaches
for decades and he fixed that and and to
me that's right oh just behind this
remarkable run of championship that's a
great achievement he also certainly did
a great job at Michigan State I put him
right at the top yeah I guess the the
indication is when the only thing you
could say about him is like how come he
can't get a consistent kicker that's
that's the only [ __ ] in the armor it's
the only Achilles heel it seems like
right just about every big game they've
lost Clemson last year was interception
but just about every big game they've
lost has had something bizarre happened
in the kicking game as I look across the
room right now and watch Gus Malzahn
enjoying his lunch that is certainly
that was there the game of the center
against LSU they missed four field goals
and even in that kick six game they
missed a bunch of field goals prior to
the last one and you're right that has
been that has been a bit of a problem
and Georgia tonight has a better field
goal kicker than Alabama
so who does Malzahn think is winning
tonight do you know I haven't I haven't
talked to him yet I think for Gus
honestly rich this is the ultimate
lose-lose situation he beat them both
and it's in both ways because he beat
them both and then because he lost the
championship game to Georgia
it's his fault that there's an All SEC
Championship game so good Gus is
probably Gus is probably rooting for
next year to get here he's Rudy who's
rooting for the final gun to self
yeah Reese take care man I look forward
to tonight at 8:00 Eastern Time when is
your coverage begin when do you start we
begin at 3:00 Eastern time will be three
to five and then six days damn well I
might have started you might be your
call times probably in five minutes
thanks for giving thanks for the call
time here Reese as always that's rece
Davis the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience